these these racial narratives are simply
ridiculous
andy no my friend you know my friend
andy no
that white supremacist according to the
left-wing media
he's a is a kind of a curious white
supremacist since he's not a white guy
but they call him that is
far right i don't even i don't even know
if he's really that right wing he just
opposes antifa he opposes political
violence he's one of the few
journalists in the country who will go
out there and actually chronicle what
antifa is doing he's got a great book
about this now
he points out that a lot of the racial
narratives are being told are just
ridiculous
that he tweeted the other day he said
i'm hearing it repeated as gospel truth
that nearly all
american mass shooters are white here
are the photos of mass shooters from
2019 defined as four or more shot in a
single incident
it shows quite a diverse set of faces
and you see when you're looking in there
you see white people you see a lot of
black people
you see what looks like some maybe
hispanic people
some other races in there as well
andy noe is now being accused of
defending white supremacy
for stating what for stating a fact for
just portraying
the depicting the number of the types of
people the races of people the
background of people who have committed
these shootings
yes that's what we're being told we're
being told that
racial bigotry is not just when you
antagonize someone for their skin or you
hate someone because
or you're making things up even when you
just state
facts even if you just
name people who commit these crimes if
you contradict the
dishonest left-wing narrative that is
somehow
bigoted and wrong
mina harris who is a niece of kamala
harris
she she tweeted out after the
horrible shooting in colorado she
tweeted out
about how this this involved white
supremacy and was so terrible then it
turned out the shooter
was not a white supremacist he was a
syrian immigrant actually
was not a christian nationalist he was a
member of a different religion
and so she she deleted the tweet but she
didn't really apologize she tweeted she
said
i deleted a previous tweet about the
suspect in the boulder shooting
i made an assumption based on his being
taken into custody alive
and the fact that the majority of mass
shootings in the u.s are carried out by
white men
so pause right there the majority of
people in the united states are white so
it would follow that crime would be
committed by the proportion of the
population but it turns out when you
look at
the number of mass shootings in the
united states
white shooters are underrepresented
given
the percentage of people in the united
states that are white
i don't think that mass shootings are
are a primarily a product of race
but mina harris does and it turns out
mina harris is completely wrong on
on all of those counts she says yeah
okay i deleted that tweet
because i i just made something up and
was
prejudiced against a racial and sexual
group
i was bigoted against them but my
bigotry
is justified that's what she's saying
she's saying my bigotry is justified
and you people who want to wait for the
truth to come out
you're you're just what are you you're
defending white supremacy or something
like that
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there